alors alors alors ça vient
c'est presque terminé pas bon pour les
pétoires et
bonjour vous savez la nouvelle je ne
serai plus jamais dérangé par monsieur
du snob ni par les autres je viens
d'installer une sonnette à la porte de
ma maison
tu veut sans doute dire françois a eu la
gentillesse de selena solide projet ça
c'est un détail sans importance 1 le
principal est que la sonnette soient
installés à l'est termine vite on
travaille de canton quand je dis plus
rien le plus difficile a été de choisir
une sonnette qui a à son mélodieux et et
harmonieux
asseyez cette fois que tenir
c'est au point f
a18 je voudrais écouter cette musique
mélodieuse et harmonieux à écoute bien
casimir
que c'est beau teddy trouve quasiment tu
trouves pas que tu aurais dû mettre une
sonnette plus enfin moins en fonction
mais ça me casse les oreilles enfin
pourquoi c'est joli on dirait un abb
fauvettes qui appelle sa maman mais moi
je trouve qu'on dirait plutôt un fauve
qui appelle son bébé bon après tout
kazimierz est assez nette ça me regarde
pas bon ben c'est terminé je te laisse
j'ai du travail on est d'accord
[Musique]
comment rester vivre jusqu'à présent
sansonnet
enfin heureusement plus personne ne
pourra me déranger
c'est le facteur bonjour casimir on a
tous courriers
qu'est-ce que tu être t'as pas l'air
dans son assiette
si si ça va ça va ça va oui a pour sûr
j'aime mieux ça tu sais allez on voit à
bientôt
il n'a même pas vu ma sonnette c'est
incroyable bon j j'ai une idée je vais
mettre une pancarte oui on verra non
mais
laisse rien
attention
à et la sonnette
voilà comme ceux ci ils ne pourront pas
dire qu'ils n'ont pas vu la sonnette
voilà
là
voilà comme ça au moins on la voile
c'est ce mec
très bien salut gaz et mire mais
jolie part par où es-tu ancrée il veut
pas le jardin pourquoi ah bon dis moi tu
as vu facteurs j'attends une lettre
urgente oui oui il vient de partir par
le petit bois la boue elle est au
courant je vais peut-être le rattrape
ici
quand on est quand même pu installer une
sonnette à la porte de derrière
ah ah ça y est
personne on se voit j'ai compris c'est
le coup classique 1 on appuie sur le
bouton et on se sauve en courant et bien
ce qui que vous soyez ce n'est pas
malade mais
il y a personne et la sonnerie continue
sarr lors
non non pas celle au téléphone oui allô
tiens il n'y a raccroché
c'est vraiment trop bête alors
dire je te salue pont qui est celui-là à
monsieur du snav et bien moi je ne vous
salue pas que la forme d'un côté joe
français casimir quoi 11 et est un
espace de débat renseignement bon enfin
casimir je veux et j'exige des excuses
des excuses ou des explications comme tu
veux vous n'avez pas lu masse honnête
oui j'ai vu la sonnette oui j'ai vu
leurs sonnettes et alors pourquoi le mou
pas appuyer dessus pour vous le savez
pas venir mais je sais lire cadets me
retenais ya marqué attention à la
sonnette ben oui où est alors alors
alors j'ai eu peur que ce soit une
sonnette fragile aux méchantes alors
j'ai bien fait attention de papier de
soie ou non non non aux
officines subissent non ici
[Rires]
[Musique]
à les
découper jury mais fasciné appuyé sur la
sellette mais enfin julie pour sûr ça
lui fera plaisir
elle est jolie à cette fan alléché rania
les pistonnés d'eau
bousculés
mais aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas tout
notre temps chez casimir nouveau avant
ce sera ratée tu as raison il sera déçu
encore une fois bon alors attention un
jeu ça
[Musique]
et là ça mérite quand même un sommet
oui oui allons allons non non non c'est
pas ça alors qu'il a
passé laissé la porte aux états unis et
c'est le on a séduit ou quand vous
exagérez un peu pourquoi enfin vous
auriez pu venir voir si vous pouviez
entrer tranquillement au lieu de sonner
et de me réveiller en plein milieu de
martiel
[Musique]